i saw that you were like in a in a jv
idol group as well
like what was that about i hated that
i hated that spill that team i never
asked without
like gotta get some tea secrets
agency was like oh you're in an idol
group now not again you're happy right
like
you're doing something beside porn so
that you're happy like you're gonna
i hated that attitude too right right
right yeah you should be grateful that
we put you in something you hate
i never ask
[Laughter]
because i don't know anything about it
so like what what was that about like
what did you have to do
was that i just sing a cover song
it wasn't even an original song oh right
right how many of you were there
at some point it became more than 15 and
again
too many oh my god because i was i was
imagining like three or four yeah i
think
idol groups here are like more we need
more because
at the time akb48 was huge yeah yeah
yeah
like wait so if we get 49
it's unstoppable because it could be 48
isn't that like
i'm sure they wanted to make it to 69
but
that would be such an amazing
conversation starter right it's like
dude my favorite idol group
yes
so wait how long did you have to do that
for uh only
for a couple months i guess because i
started being busy
i became like a free runs as an extras
like
sometimes some actually said of course
like like in the us
like you are contracted to do only with
uh what was the name of the company i
forgot like brazos
oh yeah